they asked if she would date a
a bus driver and she said only if he
owned the bus
and there was controversy because she
said she wouldn't date a bus driver
unless he owned the bus like why would
he be driving the bus if he owns it my
thing is though right is I feel like for
a lot of working class guys out here who
maybe just have a normal nine to five
maybe they have a warehouse job maybe
they work at Amazon maybe they're
delivering packages to your door it
feels like
uh there's like a a narrative being
pushed amongst the more popular women in
our culture that you know that might not
be enough these days what do you think
about like you know would you ever give
a normal guy a chance
um like a guy who made less money than
you
probably probably not like it's just you
know that's
cool for somebody else what if he's got
a plan now
no
she said because like men like to get up
they like to get up and then dip on the
person that was there when they was you
know coming up so I'd rather just just
hit me when to come up happened so you
the come-up's already asked to either
have taken place or it's in the works
like you next week you know the text in
the clear night
other than that I'm sorry and that's no
shade right that's just for me like if I
I feel like I want to feel like secure
and you know
I need the man that's supposed to
provide that's just how I feel so so you
so you like double standards when it
comes to that that's true yeah so you
wouldn't provide for a man
if you're in love
absolutely not I'm not going to be in
love with you what if you did listen
listen what if you date a lawyer right
he's really rich you fall in love you're
madly in love with him your career goes
crazy the lawyer gets disbarred yeah
okay in that circumstance that I got you
he's flat on his ass I got you
babe I'm gonna hold you down in that in
a moment but you gotta you gotta have a
plan to get that you know back in Action
now I I feel that but off the bat it's
like no okay I respect that yeah I
respect the honesty yeah
um do you got an album on the way I know
you dropped the album a couple years ago
no I don't have no album on the way but
I'm dropping singles I just did some
Regional remixes with a couple people
like I saw you did the sped up version
of this song which seems to be like
everyone's got the like yeah the like
Club Music version of their songs like
the Jersey type of vibe going on yeah
that's that's going crazy on Tick Tock
but I did some remixes with uh Lakayla
from the bay
and I did one with Kenzo bishi's from
New York I'm doing one with little Tyler
coming up and yeah he's so he's so cool
and he's a kid and I was in it I was in
a nightclub with him recently
and I just looked over and I was like
why are you supposed to be here
oh he's I think he's 16 or 17. yeah he's
not 18 or he's not even 18. I was like
why is he in here because he's cool
right he gang so you already did that
version yeah well it hasn't dropped yet
but it's on the way and then uh sexy red
I did one with her too it's coming so
I'm trying to that's got to be a very
very uh provocative song no actually
it's not provocative she was just
talking her her ones I'm interviewing
her today really yeah okay yeah we
sexy red she's a
she's free yeah we love we love the
girls that's free I saw her running
around spring break with the breasteses
out I said hey
are you a fan of Pound Town do you like
this yes yeah I love found town
yeah it's a it's a good song yeah
I feel like you do like like you're
because I think about like some of your
bigger records and they are very like
they're very uh I think that the it
gives me like OG Trina Vibe sometimes
yeah which I feel like has been kind of
missing in in well not really [__] was
kind of that you know but but it kind of
gets did you grow up listening to Trina
at all uh yes and some in some music
yeah who are you bumping as a youngin
um
I like r b Vibes I feel like I was like
listening to like Janae Aiko and like
um Aaliyah Missy Elliott Vibes like this
was my vibes when you were a kid you
were listening to Janae yeah I'm so old
man
how old are you 22. [__]
what year is that that you were born
2000 I got to tell you the right huh oh
my God yeah I remember 2000. I thought
what was you doing in 2000 [__] thinking
the world was going to end at my uncle's
house on New Year's Eve
wait no there was a time in 2020 Y2K
thing that was like a thing like you you
wouldn't know but
when 1999 was happening they said when
the clock hit 2000 like all the
computers and [__] in the world were
gonna like freeze up and like the world
was gonna like end see they that it was
a time in 2012 but they said the same
thing and I was I was 12. and like they
were like it's going to be this big
storm and all this stuff so it was
actually raining that day so I was
having a panic attack like the world is
overweight I'm only 12. it's coming yeah
isn't there a movie called 2012. I think
there's a movie yeah really
yeah yeah that's what it was that's what
it was